scrambled egg rice a vegetable smoothie
or whole-grain cereal with low-fat milk
that's how pop megastar Beyonce
described a bootylicious breakfast a few
years ago
however eating cereal has declined by
over 11 percent over the past five years
with 40% of Millennials dismissing it as
inconvenient because it involves washing
up meanwhile the kind of farming that
produces bacon and sausages is
criticized for contributing to climate
change through the carbon emissions it
produces so by the year 2030 9 meat
cereal and even dairy may be much harder
to find on the breakfast menu instead
you might be tucking into a plate of
insects according to researchers in the
Netherlands insects cost less to race
and cattle consume less water and don't
really leave a carbon footprint Plus in
many cultures around the world in fact
30% of the planet's population they're
already considered pretty tasty
Robin Shapiro founder of seek food stays
crickets are earthy and nutty which
makes them good to pair with nuts and
granola so while a rusher of Acre may
become an illicit luxury only available
in a fancy restaurant crunchy nut
cricket flakes could mean starting the
day with a bowl of creepy crawlies from
your garden biosphere probably not if
you vegan or vegetarian like one in 8
Britons now are or how about lab meat
grown from animal stem cells with no
need for real-life pigs or chickens to
become dead ones a guilt-free slice of
black pudding where there's blood on the
plate but not on your hands maybe the
thought of this has you desperately
reaching for that one cup of coffee
you're allowed per year next to climate
change rationing researchers and chefs
including Heston Blumenthal have
discovered that what you're here can
affect what you taste
so in 2039 you Cuffy might seem like
it's full of sugar even though there
isn't anything sweet in it apart from
the sound of music
with immersive dining experiences on the
rise from medieval banquets to murder
mystery stories or even a gastro physics
journey through space could breakfast of
the future be less about traditional
tastes and more about living out your
culinary dreams in a flavour filled
fantasy land by 2039 it looks like most
of us 70% in fact will live in cities to
put transport costs maybe we'll want to
grow the onions to go with our stem cell
sausages more locally however if the
current housing crisis continues and
luxury flats fill in every remaining
space where would we plant our greens
perhaps the answer is underground in
cities around the world this is already
happening
urban farmers swapped sunlight for LED
light and use a system called
hydroponics where plants are grown in
water so there's no need for soil
despite being surrounded by it perfect
for farming seaweed widely considered a
sustainable superfood of the future with
cities increasingly full of people and
traffic by 2030 ninth we may need new
ways to transport the ingredients that
end up in our breakfast could this be
where drones fly in following the rise
of take away delivery services a company
in China has been trialing drones as a
way of getting food to customers if this
takes off maybe delivery drivers will be
a thing of the past however would you be
happy to have a drone rather than a
person popping by with you music infused
coffee or seaweed sandwich spread with
increasing numbers of us working
flexibly perhaps the need for a quick
breakfast before - enough to work will
no longer be necessary
maybe instead we'll start to actually
treat breakfast as the most important
meal of the day rather than just talking
about it but whatever is on your weight
front plate you probably won't have to
wash it up afterwards because you'll be
able to eat it great news if you're a 57
year old millennial
you